forse non hai capito io la tua età Esci
dalle 8:00 di sera e tornavo a casa la
sera del giorno dopo la ma ne ho fatte
di cotto e di crude Non ti racconto
niente perché poi tua madre non mi parla
più Hai capito Senti non farla
scandalizzata che ti ho visto l'altra
sera alle 2:00 di notte con le tue
amiche ma tranquilla non dico niente a
tua madre cosa le hai raccontato pigiama
party solo lei se le può bere ste
cavolate sentia ragazzi come siamo messi
No scusa ma il biondino con occhi
azzurri che sono in classe con te con la
Chicca ma veramente ma non usciva anche
con te no ma cioè allucinati ragazzi a
quell'età sono proprio dei cretini
Infatti io sai cosa facevo la tua età
facevo con quelli più grandi che erano
più avanti di testa adesso invece sono
quelli più piccoli che mantengono
giovani hanno voglia di divertirsi ed è
dillo che sono una zia più pazzesca che
conosci A proposito volevo aspettare il
tuo compleanno ma non resistono Guarda
cosa ti ho preso la nuova limited
edition ghd ghd Elios e ghdmax cioè ma
che colori pazzeschi hanno e in più
c'era pure la pochette in omaggio hai
visto tua zia va avanti mica come tua
madre cosa ancora ai bigodini